[Music]
when I go Rachel season I was devastated
after one of the most intense
Bachelorette finales in the show's
history runner-up Peter Krause will not
be the bachelor fans were shocked and
wanted answers only ET is sitting down
with the Wisconsin native for his first
interview since the announcement when I
watched her walk away for that last time
I asked if I could go after her and I
think in my heart I knew that wasn't the
right decision to do that so yeah I just
just fade it away at that point and I
drank an entire bottle of wine were you
surprised that you fell in love with
Rachel I just went in there with an open
mind ready for love and the very first
date that I had with Rachel was probably
the best date I've ever had the
connection that she and I had that rare
first date was undeniable I felt like we
know each other for months if not years
prior to that so the stage that I got to
as the process went on yeah it was a
little surprising I didn't expect to
have that close connection that quickly
I'm a sensitive guy and you know ice to
hide for that and now I accept it and I
appreciate it and that just makes me
that much more hyper aware of the
surroundings that I'm in and The
Bachelor is a big big step that I wasn't
ready for have you spoken to her since
no another thing is people were saying I
tried to reach out to her after the show
I didn't do that either when it ended it
ended I knew that she got engaged to
Brian that very next day and that
crushed me we haven't spoken other than
at the final rose after the final rose
we said on Instagram you would have a
lot of things to say to her yeah well
along what lines with those things be
mostly thank you I mean it's fine
there's all these fan videos now out
there of the process and I watch them
cuz they're cute and the music is good
and it's hard I still get emotional
watching those videos and there is just
no closure for me it's like you know
thank you you're amazing
and it would end there so your plan from
here is to I want to continue to do my
boot camps we got a great turnout in
Madison for boys and girls but we had
almost 400 people I think show up we
raised $24,000 for the Boys and Girls
Club of Dane County and if I can do that
nationally and bring more charitable
goods to them as well as spread love
fitness and health I'm all for it
[Music]
you